MARK MIRCHANDANI: The public
sector is full of challenges
when it comes to
adopting new technology.
Join us in historic
downtown Austin, Texas
as we talk to SADA Systems
about these challenges
and how they've built dotMaps.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Thanks for joining me, Oleg.
Tell me a little
bit more about SADA.
OLEG SHALYGIN: SADA
is traditionally
a consulting company
that has migrated
users from on-prem solutions
to cloud-based platforms
like Cloud Platform.
Through that experience, we've
gained all this expertise
in various verticals,
specifically
in the public sector space.
That's where my team
comes in and helps
enable the public sector
leveraging cloud, specifically.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So from
a technical perspective,
what makes the public
sector different?
OLEG SHALYGIN: So the public
sector has unique challenges.
And traditionally, they've
been under-served by on-prem,
slow-to-roll-out solutions
that really do not scale.
And we see this very
frequently in all of the RFPs
and all of the requests for
scalability and the ability
to integrate with
various services
that they already have today.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
So what does that
look like, when they
need to come in and bring
a new solution to
something they've
been doing for 20 or 30 years?
What are the technical
challenges with that?
OLEG SHALYGIN: So the
technical challenges
there are very interesting,
because they have
a system that they use today.
And they say, look, what
you're offering is amazing.
But for the interim,
we would like
to continue to
use these systems.
And also, we have
various departments
within our organization
that are not going
to start using your system.
They're going to continue to
use the application that they're
familiar with, maybe
ArcGIS, Esri, what have you,
or some database solution,
maybe an Access database.
They're going to continue
to use that solution.
But we want
[? Atom ?] or dotMaps
to feed that data in, real
time, and integrate seamlessly,
provide rich analytics,
and so forth.
So they're not ready to
completely abandon the existing
solutions, but they
want to migrate
and start using
modern technology,
and the cloud specifically.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: But
it's also a technology
that's built on top of what they
have, not to replace all of it.
OLEG SHALYGIN: Exactly.
So what we have is, we integrate
with their existing systems,
and we're pulling data almost
real time into the application,
into the cloud,
consuming that data,
and essentially making that
workflow seamless for them.
So they're using
the existing systems
while also leveraging
the new technology
that our products offer.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So let's
talk a little bit more
about dotMaps, for example.
How is dotMaps built?
OLEG SHALYGIN: Yeah, so the
architecture of dot maps
is essentially living on GKE,
Google Kubernetes Engine.
And we're using Cloud SQL
for the data storage layer.
And essentially, it's broken up
into various microservices that
handle very specific needs.
So we have a public
portal viewer.
We have a calendar.
We have all of the
various integrations
that we have within
specific cities.
And all of those are
built and isolated
within their own
services that can then
scale up and down accordingly.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: And
that's one of the nice parts
about having the cloud.
OLEG SHALYGIN: Exactly.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So they
are able to use Google Maps
Platform to do the
actual interface,
while the work gets
done in Kubernetes
and another database.
And that's about it.
OLEG SHALYGIN: Exactly.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So when
considering that architecture,
has that helped
people start to adopt?
OLEG SHALYGIN: It has.
So the traditional
user that uses
dotMaps from the utility
space or the public space--
they're already familiar
with Google Maps.
And they want the experience
to be very, very similar.
So as with Google Maps, nobody
gets trained on Google Maps.
They just log in and,
where do I need to go?
Where are my points of interest?
What have you--
that's already there.
And that's the same
experience that we're
trying to push to our users.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Well,
thank you so much, Oleg,
for coming in and telling
us about how SADA built
these solutions in the cloud.
OLEG SHALYGIN: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Thanks for watching,
and stay tuned for
the next episode,
where we dive into the
technical side of [? Atom. ?]